Let's go on it.
Let me just,
let me just angle it.
sorry about that
Hello there.
This video has been very highly requested
throughout the whole time of slavery days.
The Molotov cocktail.
Yeah
Now you may not know,
the Molotov cocktail was invented by
Dave Molotov in 1921,
No it's Frank Molotov
Frank Molotov,
Dave Molotov invented the Frisbee
Yeah so it's true
None of that's true,
but let's do this anyway.
How do you feel
about throwing a Molotov cocktail
at the place where your grandparents live?
It's actually just by my bedroom.
It's literally just outside your bedroom.
Yeah,
all my positions are in there.
I'm not really looking
forward to actually.
Yeah, I am.
we're gonna have a great time
should we do it in your garden next?
Ah, no, too small.
And there's a cat there.
There's a cat there
Can't be loading Molotovs
when Lloyd the cat's walking
around.
I'm gonna shoot from behind Dan.
I want to see quite a lot.
So it's pretty wide lens.
Should all be in focus.
We'll see.
Exposure is low.
So we see detail in the flame.
There's a plane, that's annoying.
Don't try this at home
because of all the face melting
and stuff, let's go.
Oh hello!
Jesus Christ!
You're ready?
Yeah!
casual
Yeah it's good.
Bloody hell.
It was super effective that,
splurge of death,
Tthe fireball went up like way up there.
Then the whole of the ground was on fire.
I wish you saw my face,
it was like
They should have shown me
right at the end of high speed,
it was going like
Quick!
The wall is on fire
That's like an action scene
Well done house
nice wall
All right,
well obviously don't try that home
because you would be a tit
Oh, what an idiot do that to their house?
Instead though,
what should they do?
Probably follow us on Twitter.
Follow us on Twitter,
@GavinFree,
@DanielGruchy
You good
So weird,
do you have a broom?
Yeah there's glasses everywhere.
That was wicked.
Let's not do that again.
No